mesdames messieurs nous alertons et
sensibilisons depuis plusieurs semaines
sur le risque de reprise de l'épidémie
de covile 19 plusieurs départs de feu
ont émaillé l'été notamment en mayenne
et ont pu être gérer avec efficacité
d'autre part ce qu'a fait qu temps des
métropoles où les gens se côtoient plus
sont plus difficile à contenir
c'est désormais une réalité et vous le
savez l'épidémie est à nouveau très
actifs dans notre pays
comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays
voisins nous devons apprendre à vivre
avec le virus
pour quelques mois encore avec ces
phases aiguës d'activité qui nous oblige
à faire encore plus d'efforts et ces
périodes d'accalmies toujours en étant
attentif et pleinement acteurs de la
lutte contre l'épidémie et en conservant
notre vie sociale économique éducative
culturelle et citoyenne
combien de temps devant nous vivre avec
le virus
difficile de répondre à cette question
mais une chose est sûre nous en
apprenons chaque jour davantage sur la
copie de 19 et nous gagnons en
efficacité
vous vous interrogez légitimement sur
l'état de l'épidémie en france et sur la
stratégie que nous mettons en oeuvre
je veux aujourd'hui et conformément à la
demande du président de la république et
du premier ministre vous apporter toutes
les informations en transparence avant
toute chose je souhaite vous rappeler
notre stratégie face au co vide que nous
menons d'une manière constante et
déterminée elle repose sur quatre
piliers le premier pilier ce sont les
gestes barrière depuis le début de la
crise nous avons abondamment communiqué
pour faire la pédagogie de ses gestes
barrières ils sont d'ailleurs maintenu
maintenant connue de tous les français
qui les ont adoptées
y compris d'ailleurs le port du masque
je tiens à saluer les efforts quotidiens
consentis par les français
les résultats sont visibles mais ces
gestes ne sont pas naturels parfois même
ils peuvent être contre intuitif et puis
on a tous le sentiment qu'on est mieux
protégé qu'on est en sécurité quand on
est dans un cercle
familiale ou un cercle amical et dans
cette si longue période de crise on veut
en effet pouvoir parfois retrouvé un peu
d'insouciance
les chiffres sont désormais sans appel
la famille
les rassemblements amicaux sont des
lieux massif de contamination là aussi
des gestes barrières des réflexes de bon
sens ce sont les seules à même de nous
protéger
c'est pourquoi je vous le rappelle nous
sommes chacune et chacun d'entre nous
les acteurs clés de la lutte contre le
virus et les gestes barrière reste le
premier moyen de lutter contre
l'épidémie
en l'absence de vaccins et de
traitements efficaces nous ne répéterons
jamais assez le deuxième pilier c'est le
coeur de notre stratégie et vous le
connaissez tester alerté protéger nous
avons réussi le pari du dépistage massif
mais nous sommes au regard du nombre de
tests réalisés chaque jour confrontés à
de réelles difficultés
organisationnelles que nous devons
résoudre et sur lesquelles je reviendrai
dans quelques minutes le troisième il le
troisième pilier c'est une stratégie
différenciée adaptés à chaque territoire
lorsque la situation sanitaire d'un
territoire l'imposent
nous prenons en concertation avec les
autorités locales des mesures ciblées
pour atteindre localement les foyers
épidémiques le quatrième pilier enfin
c'est la protection des personnes âgées
et des plus vulnérables face au co vide
ce sont ces publics qui font que le coc
vide n'est pas un virus comme les autres
je voudrais pour commencer partager avec
vous ce qui se passe actuellement dans
notre pays et pourquoi c'est différent
de la première vague épidémique et enfin
vous dire ce qui nous inquiète ce qui se
passe c'est que nous constatons depuis
plusieurs semaines une accélération de
la circulation du virus
vous le savez nous avons mis en place
des outils de surveillance de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
ces outils nous permettent d'avoir une
vision très détaillée quasi en temps
réel de la diffusion du virus territoire
par territoire
ce que nous n'avions pas en amont de la
première vague ces outils nous
permettent d'anticiper et d'intervenir
de manière ciblée aujourd'hui tous ces
indicateurs montrent une progression
d'épidémie le taux d'incidence qui
compte le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations par semaine est en hausse
constante
il était hier soir dans notre pays de 83
cas pour 100000 habitants alors qu'il
était à 40 à la fin du mois d'août à 25
au milieu du mois d'août et à 10 à la
fin du mois de juillet le taux
d'incidence a dépassé pour de nombreux
départements
les différents side alerte le taux de
reproduction ensuite le fameux facteur
air qu'on vous a déjà présenté plusieurs
fois au niveau national il reste
supérieur à 1
qu'est ce que c'est que ce facteur r je
le rappelle c'est ce qui nous indique la
vitesse de circulation du virus est
combien de personne si je suis positif
je vais contaminés à mon tour
c'est là que tous nos efforts agissent
tester tracé protégé pour réduire la
vitesse de circulation du virus et les
gestes barrières et de fait le facteur
air était aux environs de 3 lorsque nous
étions au pic épidémique du printemps
dernier là il est certes supérieur à 1
ce qui veut dire que l'épidémie gagne du
terrain mais il est environ trois fois
inférieur en termes de vitesse de
circulation à ce que nous avions
constaté au printemps dernier malgré
tout un air supérieur à 1 signifie que
l'épidémie gagne du terrain et qu'elle
génère comme nous le voyons depuis
plusieurs jours de nombreuses
contaminations de nouveaux patients
hospitalisés est malheureusement de
nouvelles formes graves
j'y reviendrai mais si chacun fait un
effort supplémentaire
par exemple si chacun d'entre nous
réduisait une part de ses contacts
sociaux une part des personnes qu'il va
inviter lorsqu'il reçoit chez lui ou
faisait encore un peu plus attention à
la distance sociale et au respect des
gestes barrières on voit que le chemin
qui nous reste à parcourir pour que le r
descendent en dessous de 1 ce chemin il
nous est accessible
en parallèle de l'augmentation de
l'incidence nous constatons également
une augmentation du taux de positivité
des tests qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que sur 100 personnes chez qui
on va pratiquer un test pcr
il y avait environ une personne qui
était positive au début de l'été
désormais ce sont cinq personnes sur 100
testé qui sont positives alors que le
nombre de tests augmente
vous voyez ainsi que c'est un reflet de
la diffusion épidémique
ce qui est différent maintenant par
rapport à la première vague d'abord et
je le disais la vitesse de circulation
du virus en pratique au printemps
dernier une personne malade à lait
contaminé
deux autres personnes tous les trois
jours actuellement une personne malade
en contamine en moyenne deux autres
personnes tous les quinze jours le virus
va moins vite et c'est une différence
notable ce qui explique notamment un
profil épidémique très différent de la
première vague
ce qui est différent également ce sont
les modes de propagation du virus
je crois l'avoir répété tout l'été le
virus ne s'est jamais arrêté de circuler
nous avons pu constater qu'il a circulé
particulièrement chez les plus jeunes
d'entre nous au cours de l'été avec un
taux d'incidence de 140% mille dans la
tranche d'âge des 15 44 ans dont 50%
sont asymptomatiques
on l'a dit cet été le risque était que
le virus passe des plus jeunes qui font
moins de formes graves mais qui peuvent
en faire vers les personnes moins jeunes
et vulnérables qui elles font plus de
formes graves
c'est ce que nous observons depuis
plusieurs semaines et la figure 2 montre
très clairement les courbes que vous
avez on voit que le virus circule très
activement donc chez les 15 45 ans mais
que chez les plus de 65 ans il circule
de plus en plus et cela depuis le début
du mois d'août ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
un impact réel et visible enfin ce qui
est différent par rapport à la première
vague c'est qu'on ne se bat pas avec les
mêmes armes et que l'on connaît mieux
notre adversaire nous avons de
meilleures conditions d'hospice l
hospitalisation avec des prises en
charge
sécuriser en hospitalisation
conventionnel ce qui fait que des cas
graves qui allait au printemps dernier
en réanimation ne vont plus
nécessairement en réanimation parce
qu'il n'est parfois plus nécessaire de
les les incubés c'est à dire de leur
mettre une assistance respiratoire
massive et de la même manière il existe
un traitement qui est utilisé en
réanimation qui permet de réduire les
formes graves
il ya encore une autre différence par
rapport à la première vague au fond
j'avais expliqué en mars dernier en
faisant le tracé d'une courbe qu'il
fallait écraser la courbe pour arriver à
réduire la pression suite à lierre et
faire en sorte de ne pas arriver à la
saturation nos hôpitaux
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une courbe que
nous cherchons à aplatir à écraser c'est
autant de courbes qu'il y a de foyers
épidémiques dans les différents
territoires qui sont concernés par la
circulation active du virus vous disant
cela je vous explique par anticipation
pourquoi les mesures que nous prenons
sont différenciés territorialisée pour
tenir compte de la situation épidémique
de chaque endroit où le virus circule
je vous ai dit que j'allais vous dire
aussi ce qui nous inquiétait si la
dynamique épidémique dans certains
territoires
cette dernière conduit un taux
d'incidence dans plusieurs villes ou
départements supérieur à 150 voire 200
cas pour 100000 habitants
c'est un chiffre qui je le pense ne vous
parle pas nécessairement
sachez néanmoins que nous avons
déterminé avec les scientifiques n'est
ni des niveaux de seuil qui quand ils
sont franchies doivent nous alerter le
seuil d alerte
nous l'avions établi à 50 cas pour
100000 habitants aujourd'hui 50 53
départements ont dépassé ce seuil et
sont donc classées dans cette fameuse de
zones de circulation active du virus et
dans certains territoires notamment dans
certaines villes nous sommes d'ores et
déjà bien au delà
a marseille nous sommes à près de six
fois ce seuil en guadeloupe 5 fois ce
seuil à bordeaux à lyon quatre fois ce
seuil est à paris à plus de trois fois
ce seuil
cette dynamique épidémique atteint
désormais aussi les personnes âgées nous
l'avons vu dont on sait qu'elles sont
bien plus vulnérables face au virus
et c'est une donnée dont nous tenons
compte avec ce qu'on appelle le taux
d'incidence cette fois ci chez les
personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus ce
taux il est de 190 à marseille 130 en
guadeloupe 113 à lyon il est à plus de
80 dans plusieurs grandes villes comme
nice bordeaux lille ou toulouse
je le redis également depuis des
semaines le virus n'est pas devenu moins
dangereux avec l'été hélas est donc une
circulation plus active du virus finit
forcément par se traduire par davantage
d'hospitalisations et par davantage de
cas graves en réanimation
nous voyons aujourd'hui le nombre de
malades qu'ovide en réanimation remonter
de façon préoccupante avec des
différences significatives entre les
régions
c'est un témoin important mais c'est un
témoin tardif de l'évolution d'épidémie
et nous devons tout faire pour éviter
que ce nombre ne progresse trop en
prenant des décisions suffisamment tôt
d'abord parce que nous devons limiter au
maximum le nombre de patients qui
risquent d'entrer à l'hôpital pour cette
maladie mais aussi et surtout parce que
nos hôpitaux fonctionnent aujourd'hui de
façon très intense pour prendre en
charge nos concitoyens qui parfois ont
dû retarder leurs soins pendant la
première vague épidémique et pendant le
confinement et que nous devons à tout
prix préserver ses soins ceci dans un
contexte où en plus la fatigue des
soignants est réel les soignants dans
nos hôpitaux n'ont jamais cessé de
combattre le virus et après des mois
très éprouvant je veux ici le rendre à
nouveau hommage sur les réanimations
nous avons de surcroît réalisé un
travail de modélisation un travail de
prévision d augmentation des entrées en
réanimation
prenons l'exemple de la région paca
comme vous pouvez le voir à l'écran pour
cette région
nous disposons aujourd'hui de 537 lits
de réanimation et parmi eux 130 9
patients qu'aux vide
sont déjà hospitalisés en real c'est à
dire près de 30% alors que le
pourcentage de malades colis dans l'airé
à à l'échelle du pays et de 15% fin
septembre à l'échelle de la région paca
il y aurait 300 patients atteints du
coronavirus en réanimation
soit 60 % des lits de réa actuellement
installé à la deuxième quinzaine du mois
d'octobre si nous ne prenons pas des
mesures rapidement
nous attendrons notre capacité totale de
lits actuellement installée je parle de
lits actuellement installée parce que
nous avons aussi vous le savez la
possibilité d'armer des lits de
réanimation supplémentaires et de porter
par exemple en paca ce nombre de lits de
réa à 1000 mhz et ses leaders et à je le
disais ils sont indispensables pour
pouvoir prendre en charge des français
qui ont d'autres maladies la chirurgie
programmée
l'activité de greffe et toutes les
prises en charges aiguë de maladies
aiguës je le dis avec gravité parce que
ces chiffres qui vous paraissent
peut-être abstrait signifie que si nous
ne faisons rien nous risquons de ne plus
pouvoir prendre en charge en réanimation
tous ces patients qui en ont besoin
c'est ce constat d'une situation
dégradée dans plusieurs territoires qui
a amené le conseil de défense de
vendredi dernier
comme l'a indiqué le premier ministre a
demandé au préfet des bouches du rhône
de gironde de guadeloupe de concerter
les élus les acteurs de ce territoire
sur les mesures qu'il était nécessaire
de prendre ces mesures vous les
connaissez ces noces et notamment
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes dans les parcs sur
les plages
l'abaissement à 1000 personnes du nombre
maximal de personnes autorisées dans les
événements l'annulation de grands
événements en raison des risques
sanitaires
les contrôles du respect de ces
dispositions vont être renforcés par
ailleurs les visites dans les ehpad sont
encadrés il a été fortement recommandé
de limiter les rassemblements familiaux
et amicaux comme les mariages ou les
fêtes d'anniversaire ces mesures sont
les bonnes et je salue l'esprit de
responsabilité
dans lequel elles ont été décidées en
concertation complète avec les acteurs
locaux
cette méthode nous la revendiquons elle
fait confiance et elle met en
responsabilité les autorités locales de
l'état et les collectivités pour définir
à chaque fois la réponse la plus adaptée
vous le savez notre bagarre c'est de
mettre en place les mesures qui vont
permettre d'éviter cet affluent sur
l'hôpital c'est toujours une course
contre la montre
parce qu'il faut décider les mesures au
bon moment ni trop tôt car elles sont
contraignantes
elle ne serait pas nécessairement
acceptée par les français ni trop tard
car en fait quand on prend des décisions
elle nous a un impact sur l'évolution
des hospitalisations et des cas graves
en réa qu'avec un décalage de un
décalage de 15 jours c'est cet exercice
dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui et
qui au regard même des différences de
pression sur le système hospitalier se
déploiera de façon différenciée dans les
territoires nous gardons aujourd'hui la
même stratégie
un examen de la situation de chaque
territoire
une méthode de concertation avec les
acteurs locaux et des mesures prises
adaptée à chaque situation l'évolution
des indicateurs épidémiologique nous
conduisent à retenir la même approche
pour les agglomérations de lyon et de
nice lyon je le disais se caractérise
par un taux d'incidence très élevé de
204 x la cote d' alerte avec un impact
fort chez les personnes de plus de 65
ans l'incidence yen à 113 nice un taux
d'incidence de 153 fois la cote d'
alerte mais il est proche des 100 pour
les personnes de plus de 65 ans et
surtout la part des patients qu'aux vide
dans les réanimations de la région paca
je le disais tout à l'heure a atteint
les 30% nous avons donc demandé au
préfet du rhône et des alpes maritimes
de concerter avec les élus et les
acteurs du territoire pour proposer au
gouvernement d'ici samedi
les mesures qui devront être prises pour
enrayer la circulation du virus et
limiter son impact sur le système
sanitaire
les maires de nice et de lyon
ont d'ailleurs déjà commencé à prendre
des mesures par anticipation le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ont souhaité que la plus grande
transparence soit faite et que de la
prési prévisibilité soit donnée à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous c'est ce
que je fais ici en indiquant les
situations territoriales qui nous
inquiète et qui devront faire l'objet de
décisions la semaine prochaine si la
situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas
dans ces territoires dans les
territoires pour lesquels des mesures
fortes ont déjà été prises
particulièrement marseille et la
guadeloupe
si la situation sanitaire ne s'améliore
pas et si le nombre d'entrées en
réanimation continue à croître
il faudra sans doute prendre des mesures
encore plus fortes
elles seront naturellement décidé au
niveau local mais je pense en
particulier à la possible fermeture des
bars ou à l'interdiction de
rassemblements publics à lille toulouse
rennes dijon et paris
le taux d'incidence en population
générale est élevé de l'ordre de 3 à 4
fois la cote d' alerte et le taux
d'incidence pour les personnes âgées de
plus de 65 ans dépasse la cote d' alerte
les uns et critiques ne sont pas encore
atteint mais nous serons extrêmement
attentifs à l'évolution de la situation
dans ces métropoles passé ce point
épidémiologique
je voudrais revenir un instant à notre
stratégie et vous parlez des tests dans
ce contexte de forte reprise épidémique
il est plus que jamais nécessaire de
continuer à traquer les russes cela
repose sur notre stratégie que vous
connaissez bien tester alerté protéger
testé pour identifier les porteurs du
virus
alertés en repérant les chaînes de
transmission du virus
et en prévenant les personnes
susceptibles d'être contaminés protéger
en isolant au plus vite les porteurs et
les cas contacts pour freiner la
circulation virale
nous avons fait le choix en france de
permettre à chaque français qui le
souhaitent
et quelle qu'en soit la raison de
bénéficier d'un test gratuitement et
sans ordonnance
cette stratégie assumée vise à
identifier un maximum de porteurs du
virus y compris et notamment d'ailleurs
parmi les publics asymptomatiques
pour accompagner cette stratégie nous
avons augmenté de manière très
significative nos capacités de
prélèvements et des analyses
cette semaine nous avons dépassé les 1
million 200 mille tests réalisés sur une
seule semaine
cette stratégie fait de la france l'un
des pays dans lesquels le plus de tests
sont réalisés et là je tiens à remercier
les laboratoires les préleveurs les
médecins les biologistes les techniciens
de laboratoire dans les hôpitaux et en
ville je sais l'effort inédit que nous
leur demandons la pression qui est la
leur jeu c'est l'effort qu'il réalise
dans des conditions qui sont devenues
difficiles
toutefois une conséquence directe de
cette stratégie de test à grande échelle
c'est un embouteillage un embouteillage
dans l'accès aux tests surtout dans
certaines grandes villes là où le virus
circule beaucoup et je voudrais d'abord
remercier les français pour leur
patience et leur compréhension
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
instauré une doctrine de priorisation
des tests avec une liste de personnes
prioritaires les personnes qui disposent
d'une prescription médicale les
personnes symptomatique les soignants
les aides à domicile et les cas
contactez le rôle des médecins
généralistes dans cette priorisation est
important et c'est pourquoi les
personnes disposant d'une prescription
médicale sont naturellement prioritaires
et là je souhaite aussi remercier
l'ensemble des soignants qui ont ville
font face à cette résurgence du virus
parmi vous je sais qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont prioritaires dans
l'accès aux tests mais qui n'arrivent
pas à obtenir un rendez-vous dans un
délai ou un résultat de test dans un
délai raisonnable sachez que nous
faisons le maximum pour corriger cette
situation dans les meilleurs délais
d'abord en vous réservant des plages
horaires dans les laboratoires ensuite
en installant des tentes ou des centres
de dépistage qui vous seront dédiés dans
toutes les grandes villes pour l'île de
france ce sont 20 centres de prélèvement
pour les publics prioritaires qui vont
être déployés à paris à trappes a bondi
à evry à compter de lundi prochain
il vient de s'ajouter aux 590
laboratoire qui réalise des tests pcr
ces centres seront près de 8 heures à 14
heures au public prioritaire et pourront
réaliser au moins 500 tests pcr chacun
par jour leur localisation qui a été
discuté avec les élus sur un rendu
public très prochainement
sachez aussi que si vous n'êtes pas
prioritaire vous devrez parfois accepter
d'attendre plusieurs jours pour être
testé par ailleurs il ne sert à rien de
se tester
trop souvent le test n'est pas un geste
barrière le test doit être fait si vous
avez un doute parce que vous avez des
symptômes ou si vous êtes un cas contact
avéré qu'à contact avéré c'est que vous
avez été en contact et normalement
appelée par l'assurance maladie la rs ou
par le proche qui a été malade
si vous avez mangé avec quelqu'un hier
soir et que cette personne vous rappelle
aujourd'hui pour vous dire que son fils
fréquente la classe d'un enfant qui a de
la fièvre
vous n'êtes pas qu'à contacter les cas
contacts de cas contacts ne sont pas des
cas contacts se teste ensuite un intérêt
si vous respectez les allemands par dont
l'expression mais il faut assurer la
priorité aux prioritaire je terminerai
sur les tests en vous donnant quelques
perspectives sur les innovations qui
vont arriver dans les prochaines
semaines elles sont de deux natures les
tests antigénique et les tests
salivaires
qu'est ce qu'un test antigénique alors
si vous passer le test vous ne verrez
pas la différence a priori l'opérateur
introduit un écouvillon par voie naso
pharyngé pour réaliser ce prélèvement
mais ensuite ce que ça change au lieu
que l'opérateur envoie les coûts villon
dans un laboratoire
il va pouvoir réaliser directement
l'analyse du test avec un résultat qui
rendu généralement en moins de 30
minutes
plusieurs de ces tests ont obtenu des
autorisations de commercialisation
il pourrait devenir ils pourraient
devenir demain un complément utile voire
très utile notamment dans les stratégies
de dépistage dans la tente des
recommandations des autorités
scientifiques
nous avons autorisé et initier des
expérimentations en ile de france vont
être déployés deux premières opérations
de test antigénique grâce aux hôpitaux
parisiens de l'ap-hp dont les équipes
scientifiques ont réalisé un travail
indispensable pour qualifier ces tests
elles s'inscrivent dans les 300
opérations de test ciblées conduites par
la rs ile-de-france qui permettront de
calais la méthode et l'efficacité de
cette ressource nouvelle mais en matière
de tests comme pour toutes les réponses
à une crise comme celle ci il faut
d'abord vérifier la robustesse des
outils et des procédures sans attendre
nous avons également d'ores et déjà
passé des premières commandes à hauteur
de cinq millions de tests antigénique
qui seront arrivées d'ici à début
octobre
sans attendre nous travaillons à une
stratégie de déploiement et j'ai fait le
choix de préparer cette stratégie en
collaboration étroite avec mon homologue
allemand qui est ainsi sur la même
trajectoire que nous ensuite les tests
salivaires qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
test salivaire
alors cette fois ci c'est vous qui
passait un test vous verrez la
différence puisque au lieu d' un
écouvillon naso pharyngé au lieu du
grand coton tige on va vous prélevez
l'opérateur voo prélèvera un peu de
salive qu'il enverra ensuite au
laboratoire
hélas la suite est la même que pour les
tests pcr classique
des études ont été lancées cet été à ma
demande et nous attendons désormais de
façon imminente
l'avis de la haute autorité de santé
pour déterminer quel public et dans
quelles conditions ces tests salivaires
pourrait être réalisée je reviendrai
sans doute plus longuement sur ces deux
innovations la semaine prochaine un mot
enfin sur le sujet des enfants
le haut conseil de la santé publique
nous a rendu aujourd'hui même un avis et
qui sera publié ce soir indiquant je
cite les enfants jeunes sont peu à
risque de formes graves et peu actif
dans la chaîne de transmission du
coronavirus les données de la
littérature montre à ce stade des
connaissances que le risque de
transmission existe principalement
d'adulte à adulte d'adultes et enfants
mais rarement d'enfants enfants ou
d'enfants à adultes c'est une
information importante
elle a notamment des conséquences
directes sur la scolarité de nos enfants
cela signifie que les enfants en
primaire en maternelle en crèches sont
peu susceptibles de se contaminer entre
eux et de contaminer les adultes autour
d'eux lorsqu'un enfant est testé positif
souvent parce qu'il a été contaminé au
sein de sa famille il doit être isolé
sept jours chez lui mais les autres
enfants de sa classe pourront
normalement continuer à se rendre à
l'école
cela vaut aussi pour les jeunes enfants
qui sont accueillis en crèche ou chez un
assistant maternel
il est bien évident que la situation est
différente
si plusieurs enfants d'une même classe
sont positifs et si il y à une chaîne de
transmission manifeste en revanche nous
allons renforcer les mesures pour
limiter autant que possible les
contaminations d'adultes et enfants
comme cela est le cas à l'école le port
du masque sera désormais obligatoire
pour tous les professionnels de crèches
y compris en présence des enfants
même si des dérogations pourront être
envisageable par exemple et bien sûr
avec des enfants qui présenteraient des
troubles du comportement
ces nouveaux éléments vont nous
permettre dans les tout prochains jours
d'assouplir le protocole sanitaire dans
les écoles et dans les crèches
le ministre jean michel blanquer
reviendra plus précisément sur tous ces
éléments relatifs à l'éducation
nationale mais notre message est clair
les enfants doivent aller à l'école et
il n'y a pas lieu de renvoyer les élèves
chez eux voire de fermer des
établissements entiers à la première
alerte
si les enfants sont peu concernés par le
cos vide c'est le contraire pour nos
aînés aussi avant de finir et et de
prendre les questions posées sur les
réseaux puis ensuite mesdames et
messieurs les journalistes de prendre
vos questions j'aimerais m'adresser
particulièrement aux personnes âgées qui
nous écoutent les mois de confinement
ont été difficiles ils ont même été très
pénible et je mesure croyez le bien les
sacrifices consentis par chacun d'entre
vous mais nous le savons vous êtes les
personnes les plus fragiles face au co
vide et notamment face aux formes graves
de la maladie
c'est pourquoi je vous demande de vous
protéger encore davantage
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous
l'immense majorité d'entre vous respecte
scrupuleusement les gestes barrière
respectent les consignes de sécurité et
de prudence
depuis des mois vous faites tous les
jours des choix compliqués vous poser
beaucoup de questions pour continuer à
avoir une vie de famille une vie sociale
tout en vous protégeant j'en suis
pleinement conscient mais nous sommes
dans une situation particulièrement dans
les territoires dont nous avons parlé il
ya quelques minutes dans une situation
qui est telle que je ne peux que vous
demandez à vous aussi de redoubler tous
vos efforts y compris celui le plus
difficile qui consiste à réduire encore
le nombre de personnes que vous voyez
chaque jour en conclusion
certains pourraient s'étonner des
messages passés aujourd'hui d'un côté
nous ramenons la durée l'isolément à
sept jours nous adaptons les règles pour
nos enfants
de l'autre côté nous durcissons les
restrictions dans les métropoles et nous
envoyons un message d' alerte aux
personnes âgées
cette décision relève directement de la
connaissance
note que nous avons aujourd'hui du virus
et qui nous permet de mieux cibler nos
interventions nous savons que les
personnes positives sont surtout
contagieuse les tout premiers jours
nous savons que les enfants transmettent
peu le virus nous savons que les
personnes en réanimation sont
essentiellement des personnes âgées
nous savons que les chaînes de
contamination sont plus fréquentes dans
les métropoles que dans les zones
rurales
nous sommes encore suffisamment en amont
pour opérer ce pilotage fin dans la
lutte contre le virus
je vous remercie quelques questions
posées sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne comprends pas à partir de quand il
faut que j'applique la cep thèmes
d'isolement de mon test des premiers
symptômes
en la matière nous avons choisi la
méthode claire un protocole simple et
lisible pour tous c'est la méthode qu'on
pourrait appeler des trois sets
l'isolément ces 7 jours 7 jours après
l'apparition des symptômes quand on est
malade isolement ces sept jours après un
test positif quand on est asymptomatique
et l' isolement ces sept jours après le
dernier contact avec une personne malade
après réalisation d'un test à sept jours
et je me permets de rappeler que quand
on n'est qu'à contacter il n'est pas
utile d'aller faire un test
immédiatement quand on nous dit qu'on
n'est qu'à contacter quand on nous dit
qu'on n'est qu'à contacter on reste chez
soi et sept jours après le dernier
contact avec la personne malade on va se
faire tester et si le test est négatif
alors on peut sortir de la période
d'isolement pendant avec prudence
pendant encore une semaine
en privilégiant pour le coup le masque
chirurgical et en faisant attention aux
interactions sociales
mon enfant a des maux de tête un rhume
dois-je l'envoyer à l'école
oui si l'état de santé de l'enfant est
compatible avec le fait d'aller à
l'école oui il ne faut pas évincer soi
même ses enfants de l'école s'ils n'ont
pas une fièvre des symptômes et si c'est
un rhume parce que le rhume commencent à
arriver dans notre pays on est forcément
tous alerté par des situations d'enfants
qui n'ont pas le coc vide mais qui ont
une année qui coule et pas de symptômes
graves en cas de doute on appelle le
médecin mais on scolarise son enfant que
se passe-t-il en université
et si en étudiant est positif au cou vie
de 19 le protocole universitaire il
repose sur quatre niveaux d'action
graduée en fonction de la situation
il fait appel à une interprétation un
regard local systématique par les
autorités sanitaires notamment par l'
agence régionale de santé
si un étudiant est positif dans un amphi
étant donné qu'il ya le respect des
gestes barrières le port du masque voir
la distanciation social à chaque fois
que c'est possible
il ya ce qu'on appelle une enquête de
traçage comme chez n'importe qui qui
réalisait et les cas contacts sont alors
identifié pourquoi la région parisienne
n'était pas concerné par un durcissement
des mesures comme à bordeaux ou à
marseille j'ai présenté les trois
niveaux qui doivent alerter et qu'ils
doivent faire prendre des mesures
adaptées est proratisé à la gravité sur
le territoire l'incidence en population
générale
l'incidence chez les personnes âgées
vulnérables et le taux d'occupation des
réanimations paris ne répond pas à
l'ensemble de ces critères mais je les
cités parmi les grandes métropoles au
sein desquels il est urgent de freiner
la circulation active du virus sans quoi
des mesures pourrait être décidée d'ici
à quelques jours nous suivons cela au
quotidien
je n'ai pas envie de télécharger ce top
cow vide j'ai l'impression que ça ne
sert à rien que là vous avez tort stop
que vit de ça marche
stop cowitz est une application qui est
gratuite qui est anonymisé qui est
sécurisé et qui doit nous aider à lutter
contre la circulation du virus
je vais vous dire moi je vous demande de
télécharger ce top cow vite sur votre
téléphone
si vous n'avez pas envie de le brancher
toute la journée où toutes les nuits je
vous demande au moins dans ce cas là de
le brancher lorsque nous appuyer sur
votre appli ça marche très bien et de
l'utiliser quand vous allez par exemple
aller dans un bar ou dans tout autre
lieu faire la fête avec des copains ou
quand vous allez dans un endroit où vous
n'êtes pas sûr de pouvoir respecter la
distance sociale stock co vide c'est un
moyen pour vous sur anonyme d'être
informés dès lors que vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter ça n'en portent pas de
conséquence obligatoire sur vous ça vous
informe que vous n'êtes qu'à contacter
et ça vous donne toute la conduite à
tenir et c'est aussi une mine
d'informations une application qui
fonctionne bien et près de 3 millions de
français qui l'ont téléchargée il faut
que nous soyons plus
le faire en tout cas un mot clé sur mon
téléphone et ça fonctionne j'ai entendu
dire qu'on pouvait payer pour avoir un
test plus rapidement dans certains
laboratoires
c'est vrai j'espère que c'est faux en
tout cas si c'est vrai sachez que c'est
illégal
la totalité des tests pcr réalisés dans
notre pays sont pris en charge à 100%
par l'assurance maladie à 100%
vous n'avez rien à débourser pas un euro
c'est à dire que si un laboratoire vous
propose des passe droits ou des coupes
fils si ça devait exister des enquêtes
de l'assurance maladie sont conduites et
nous y mettrons un terme et aux
questions des journalistes
bonjour si le blanc d'oeuf de la peine
j'ai deux petites questions alors sur
les hôpitaux
combien de plans blancs étaient
déclenchées et combien de lits de
réanimation supplémentaires ont été
ouverts et ensuite j'ai une question sur
les tests salivaires et antigénique quel
est ce qu'ils vont être remboursés à
quel taux et et quand est ce que ce sera
tous les tests qu un marquage serré ou
seulement ceux qui sont validées par le
cnr à vous poser une question qui était
fondamentale celle du blanc blanc pour
mémoire le plan blanc c'est quand on
demande aux hôpitaux de déprogrammer
parmi les éléments du plan blanc de
déprogrammer les soins programmés
notamment les soins chirurgicaux pour
libérer les lits de réanimation et ne
plus utiliser les blocs opératoires
qu'on peut alors transformer en lit de
réanimation supplémentaires je les dis
nous avons un impératif de pouvoir
soigner les françaises et les français
qui ont besoin de soins
orco vide et beaucoup d'opérations de
greffes ont été différées dans le temps
pendant la période de confinement et
doivent reprendre donc le plan blanc il
est déclenchée dans chaque territoire et
dans chaque établissement de santé
lorsque la situation le nécessite et que
nécessite parfois de rappeler des
équipes d'augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation ne voulons pas arriver à une
situation qui nous obligerait à des
programmes et les soins parce que c'est
absolument fondamental sur la deuxième
question que vous posez sur les tests
antigénique et salivaires sur le
remboursement
on n'est pas encore au stade de
remboursement de ces tests on est au
stade de l'expérimentation de la
qualification en vie réelle à une
échelle importante je le disais en
ile-de-france et j'attends les
recommandations des autorités
scientifiques
on travaille je le disais main dans la
main avec nos voisins allemands mais
également avec nos voisins italiens pour
déterminer les bonnes conditions d'usagé
lorsque nous avons déterminé des bonnes
conditions d usage nous rembourserons
ces tests même titre que nous les
remboursons pour la pcr caroline cox
georges pour mediapart oui c'est sur le
dépistage donc à la fois les biologie du
public et du privé font de leur désarroi
ils sont réellement en danger et ils
sont
désemparés devant des domaines de test
assez matif par exemple dans les
universités où il ya des clusters qui
apparaissent la question que je vous
pose c'est ce qu'il faut pas abandonner
distinguer un dépistage de diagnostic
vers les personnes prioritaires
et puis un dépistage plus de masse avec
des nouveaux outils d dans quel délai
vous pouvez arriver vers ça c'est le
conseil scientifique évoque sa aussi
dansant alors pour ted résumé la
question il ya deux stratégies
effectivement il ya ce qu'on appelle le
diagnostic et il ya ce qu'on appelle le
dépistage le diagnostic c'est si vous
venez me voir et que vous me dites j'ai
de la fièvre j'ai des symptômes
je vous faire un diagnostic pour voir si
vous êtes positive au virus
le dépistage chez mettons je décide de
voir qu'elle est là le taux de
positivité au cours d'un virus parmi un
panel de 20 journalistes rassemblés dans
une pièce et que là on va faire presque
aveugle des tests c'est un porte des
conséquences en terme de deux niveaux
d'exigence de sensibilité du test je
pars entre ici dans les détails mais
vous avez raison de poser la question du
distinguo entre les deux lui beaucoup de
barnum d'opérations extérieures des
dépistages en milieu asymptomatiques qui
ont été conduits certains d'ailleurs
nous ont amenés à identifier des cas qui
sont positifs et d'autres non ce que je
souhaite c'est que nous puissions
orienté tout ou partie de ces barnum là
où le virus circule activement pour voir
prendre cette fois ci en priorité les
cas asymptomatiques les personnes avec
prescription les cas contactez les
soignants et les aides à domicile c'est
à dire les publics prioritaires
bonjour julien van aelst pour bfm tv
monsieur le ministre ce jeudi l' oms a
alerté sur le niveau de transmission du
coup vide en europe considérée comme je
cite inquiétant l'organisation
internationale fait aussi part de ses
critiques concernant les le fait de
raccourcir la quarantaine dans certains
pays c'est le cas en france qui est donc
passé à une certaine dès lors allez vous
prendre en compte cet avis de l' oms est
par exemple repasser à une quatorzaine
dans les zones où le virus circule
activement comme par exemple nice ou
lyon loi mais ce n'est pas une critique
sur la réduction de la durée de la de la
quarantaine l'om asie il faut à faire
attention à ce que les gens comprennent
ce que ça implique comme changement
vous savez on a fait le constat en
france qu'on avait parfois et souvent
même est de plus en plus de difficultés
à faire respecter la mise à l'abri des
personnes qui sont qu'un contact ou qui
conte son cas positifs il ya des coups
de sonde qui sont passés par les
autorités sanitaires et qui montrent que
ça devient de plus en plus compliqué de
faire respecter cela alors que vous
pouvez tester autant que vous voulez si
quand vous diagnostiquez quelqu'un pour
le coronavirus il ne resterait que tu
pas et ne respecte pas la mise à l'abri
le test aura servi à rien donc c'est
absolument essentiel
or ce que nous disent les autorités
scientifiques que nous avons saisi sur
cette question avant évidemment de
prendre une décision c'est que
l'adhésion des français sera bien
meilleur si ces sept jours et pas 14
et par ailleurs il ya un argument de
fond qui est un argument scientifique et
médicale c'est que la plupart l'immense
majorité des des symptômes apparaissent
dans les tout premiers jours
est ce qu'on appelle la contagiosité
c'est à dire la capacité que j'ai de
transmettre le virus à quelqu'un si j'en
suis moi même porteur elle l'est devient
très faible au delà de cinq jours on
estime qu'elles seraient de l'ordre de
5% ou à partir du 7ème jour elle reste
résiduelle de l'ordre de 2 à 4 % au bout
de 14 jours dont vous voyez ce que vous
perdez entre guillemets entre le 7e et
14e jour vous le gagnez en faisant mieux
et mieux respecter et mieux appliquer la
quarantaine
beaucoup d'autres pays sont en train de
le faire la suède a été le premier pays
à le faire mais d'autres états avec qui
je suis en entretien régulier sont déjà
passés à dix jours et envisage demain de
passer à 7 jours bonjour monsieur le
ministre sam hill 5 6 pour le groupe
canal+ ses news
selon certaines sources monsieur le
ministre lors du conseil de défense de
vendredi dernier vous auriez suggéré au
président de la république de mettre en
place des mesures beaucoup plus
drastiques que celles que vous avez
présenté aujourd'hui vous auriez aussi
essuyé un refus catégorique de la part
du président qui souhaite visiblement se
focaliser sur la priorisation des tests
d'abord est-ce que vous confirmer cette
information est ensuite est ce qu il ya
de la friture sur la ligne entre le
président et son ministre en pleine
crise sanitaire merci alors je vous
répond très clairement un conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale dans
son seul intitulé il oblige le respect
je n'ai pas vocation à vous dire ce que
nous échangeons avec le prétend la
république ou avec l'ensemble des
personnes autour de la table dans un
conseil de défense si je le faisais ce
serait grave par ailleurs j'ai la
confiance du président de la république
nous en avons échangé encore tout à
l'heure nous sommes parfaitement en
ligne sur la stratégie qu'il a même
stratégie que celle que nous utilisons
depuis maintenant des mois et nous
formons un pack avec le gouvernement
avec le premier ministre jean castex
avec qui nous avions travaillé aussi
étroitement pour le plan de
déconfinement du pays donc rassurez vous
tout va bien et on travaille c'est ça
l'essentiel je le ministre on la retire
au quotidien jeu permet de rebondir sur
la question de mon confrère on a quand
même pu lire partout dans la presse que
lors de ce conseil de défense et bien
macro avait été très dure avec vous ils
vous reprocher donc principalement
d'avoir foule voulu fermer les bars et
restaurants à bordeaux et marseille mais
aussi ses interminables files d'attentes
devant le laboratoire et le délais
d'attentes pour les résultats on a pu
lire durant la presse un million de
tests par semaine c'est bien beau mais
si les résultats arrivent trop tard ça
ne sert à rien vous reviendrez me voir
quand votre copie sera meilleur vous at
il dit c'est lorsqu'on accueillir dans
la presse votre copie était le meilleur
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous vous sentez
sur la même ligne sur le fond que
l'elysée pour la phase 2 du plan coville
est ce que vous êtes sûre sauf votre
respect que vous voulez entre guillemets
utiliser une des questions vous pouvez
me poser aujourd'hui sur la circulation
virale avec le niveau d'angoissé des
français et d'attentes quant à
l'information qu'ils ont envie de
recevoir sur mon cas personnel moi je
n'en suis pas sûr mais je crois avoir
répondu à notre confrère tout à l'heure
que tout allait bien qu'on est en phase
et quant au contenu du conseil de
défense la même réponse que tout à
l'heure j'ai répondu sur la question de
la longueur des tests qu'il ya
effectivement des embouteillages des
embouteillages qui sont notamment dans
les métropoles dans lesquels le virus
circule activement plus vous avez une
malade
plus vous avez de cas contacts et donc
plus vous avez des publics prioritaires
et donc localement à l'échelle
essentiellement des métropoles parce que
c'est là que le virus circule de plus
les labos font face à une demande
massive important de tester pour ça
qu'on apporte du renfort et qu on
réoriente les dépistage en population
asymptomatiques vers les diagnostics
auprès des publics qui sont les plus à
risque de présenter le virus en tout cas
qu'ils font partie des publics
prioritaires
il n'a pas de carence en réactifs comme
je peux lire parfois d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des industriels qui
produisent et réactif
on fait une communication hier ou
avant-hier pour expliquer que nous
disposions en stock de 2 x 2 2 x les
besoins actuellement utilisés en
réactifs
donc c'est un problème d'organisation
nous avons demandé aux agences
régionales de santé de réunir l'ensemble
des acteurs publics et privés
j'ai moi même appelé ça m'arrive des
laboratoires publics à l'hôpital est
privé pour voir avec eux la situation
lorsqu'il présentait des délais qui
étaient trop longs parfois ça tient à
pas grand chose
parfois ça tient vraiment au fait qu'il
ya tellement de malades qui se pressent
au laboratoire au même endroit que c'est
compliqué on est en train d'y apporter
une solution hors de question bonjour
monsieur le ministre et le nord perron
pour tf1 lci deux questions en une vous
avez parlé des mesures d'assouplissement
dans les écoles est ce que ça concerne
également les collèges est ce que les
les collégiens pourraient être dispensés
du port du masque est pourquoi attendre
ville par ville que les mesures que les
cas que les chiffres augmentent pour
prendre des mesures alors qu'elles
pourraient peut-être être davantage
anticipé alors j'ai jamais dit qu'on
allait retirer le masque aux collégiens
quand on dit assouplir ça veut dire
quelles sont les réactions quelles sont
les actions à mener
lorsqu on identifie un cas positif dans
une école et j'ai précisé que nous
attendions le verdict des autorités
sanitaires en tout cas leur orientation
et que c'est au ministre de l'éducation
nationale que de revenir vers vous pour
présenter les choses dans les tout
prochains jours
sur la deuxième question que vous avez
posé qui traitait de pardon pourquoi
attendre pour appliquer des mesures
ben si je vais expliquer aux habitants
de dordogne qu'il faut limiter les
rassemblements
et que il ya plus grand événement alors
que le virus circule de mémoire beaucoup
moins qu'ailleurs
je pense que l'adhésion des habitants
sera sans doute moins bonne et moi je
préfère que l'adhésion soit forte et que
les mesures soient comprises qu'on veut
c'est donner de la visibilité est ce que
j'ai fait là comme exercice d'indiquer
un certain nombre de métropoles de
territoires dans lesquels parce que le
virus circule activement on pourrait
demain être amené à prendre dès ce qu'on
appelle des mesures de gestion
c'est pour permettre à chacun en
connaissance de cause de savoir ce qui
pourrait arriver si le virus continue de
circuler aussi fort et aussi vite voir
si sa circulation augmente et donc
fonctionner de façon différenciée
ça fait sens et à les mettre des mesures
de gestion de restriction dans les
endroits où le virus circule un navire
se peut ça n'aurait pas de sens en tout
cas si vous étiez habitants de ces
territoires je pense que vous y soyez
sensible
bonjour frédérique prabonnaud france
télévisions j'aurais juste une pression
sur les tests est-ce que remettre une
prescription obligatoire pour faire les
tests et une piste envisagée si la
priorisation ne marche pas et juste une
petite précision est ce que les aides à
domicile sont dans les publics
prioritaires pour les tests les aides à
domicile font partie du public
prioritaire parce qu'elles interviennent
ils interviennent au domicile des
personnes par définition souvent
vulnérables donc ils font partie de
cette liste
et sur la question de la prescription ça
fait partie des questions qu'on discute
qu'on réfléchisse si vous posez la
question d'ailleurs c'est parce que
c'est une question qui mérite réflexion
quand j'en discute avec des
scientifiques des médecins des gens qui
s'intéressent et qu'ils connaissent
comment les choses se passent en
pratique ils me disent si on restera une
prescription on risque d'avoir deux
impacts
le premier c'est qu'on va peut-être
ajouter 24 ou 36 heures qui peut être
parfois le délais de rendez vous pour
pouvoir avoir une ordonnance donc
finalement va rallonger les choses ce
qui est pas terrible et ils me disent
ils me disent également qu'un certain
nombre de personnes qui a symptomatique
vont aller font spontanément se faire
tester parce que il se pose la question
sont aujourd'hui diagnostic positive et
ne le ferai plus de demain je vous
rappelle que notre stratégie de ce point
de vue là elle a évolué de façon
importante et c'est pour ça que le
nombre de tests a augmenté de façon
importante
si on mettait une prescription je ne
suis pas sûr que on améliore fortement
les délais en revanche on
risque d'assister à une réduction du
nombre de tests réalisés et donc à une
réduction du nombre de cas positifs
identifié maintenant ça ne faut jamais
dire jamais comme disait l'autre on
regarde la situation comment est-ce
qu'elle évolue mais la priorisation et
les moyens que nous mettons en oeuvre
qui sont des moyens opérationnels très
fort et très rapide dans les territoires
concernés devraient nous permettre de
répondre à cet enjeu sans avoir sans
avoir besoin d'en arriver là
je vous remercie